alexis poulard en mangeant merci d'être
en direct avec nous alors on vient de le
dire 25 ordonnance ont été adoptés déçu
de ce conseil ait des ministres dont ce
fonds de solidarité d'un milliard
d'euros qui va être mis en place par les
entreprises une première réaction sur
cette mesure c'est bien de d'essayer de
sauver les entreprises
ce serait bien d'essayer de sauver aussi
les français je vois que on parle
beaucoup de mesures économiques parce
qu'effectivement la crise économique va
être extrêmement importante mais pour ce
qui est de la réponse sanitaire à cette
crise
depuis le début et bien c'est un échec
échec du confinement dans les clusters
échec de la première semaine de
confinement échec de tout ce qui a été
fait puis incapacité de fournir les
soignants ceux qui sont en première
ligne avec des masques avec du gel avec
les éléments essentiels pour mener le
combat contre ce virus et on attend ce
week-end des chiffres catastrophiques
dans les hôpitaux sans compter les ehpad
et les personnes âgées qui décède à
domicile donc très bien l'économie
d'accord attention attention à ces lois
d'exception parce qu'on les connaît
c'est souvent des lois scélérates qui
reste après la crise et quand on voit
l'empressement quel gouvernement à
casser le code du travail avec des
semaines de 60 heures avec cette envie
de faire en sorte que pour la reprise il
va falloir que les français travail
travail travail et travaille encore
après avoir passé des semaines en
confinement
il va falloir extrêmement vigilants à
nos droits et nos libertés
non mais dans philippe arles a tout de
même rappelé 1 c'est un droit du travail
ont ménagé temporairement en tout cas
c'est ce qu'il dit certains regrettent
que certaines dispositions sont
favorables aux employeurs est pas
favorable aux employés évidemment mais à
quoi s'attendre avec la république en
marche quand on leur propose alors pour
eux c'est très simple on doit tous être
mobilisés on doit faire l'union
nationale mais l'union elle se fait que
d'un côté et c'est un peu comme en temps
de guerre qui on en voit dans les
tranchées les ouvriers les salariés les
précaires ceux qui n'ont pas le droit en
fait finalement et puis l'aristocratie
financière est à l'arrière et continue
de faire des affaires c'est ce qu'on
voit dans les différentes bourses on
voit les grands patrons qui rachètent
des actions à bas prix
de leur entreprise pour qu'elle ne soit
pas rachetés par d'autres évidemment
mais on voit bien qu'on parie sur la
reprise du monde d'hier tel qu il était
après cette crise et que ceux qui vont
bien en pâtir le plus ce sont les plus
les pulls précaires ceux qui n'ont pas
le droit au chapitre les rien comme le
disait modèle macron ces riens qui font
tenir l'économie aujourd'hui je ne crois
pas qu'on leur donnera beaucoup après
malheureusement la preuve en est toutes
les lois qui sont en train d'être votée
sont pour davantage de contrôler
davantage de travail davantage de
pression sur les salariés mais
certainement pas pour l'augmentation des
salaires l'égalité des salaires l'arrêt
de des dividendes que les dividendes
soient reversés pour l'effort de
production rien sur la production de
masse rien sur la production de gel
rien sur la construction d'hôpitaux de
campagne sis est une guerre alors on est
très mal très mal loti avec des généraux
pareil donc vous semblez donc dire que
le gouvernement français aujourd'hui a
très mal anticipé cette crise qu'elle
soit là sanitaires ou économique
ils se sont donc trompés sur toute la
ligne selon vous qu'est ce que vous
proposez corps est dit qu aurait dû
faire le gouvernement français faire
face à cette crise et où est-ce que
exactement deux se sont trompés c'est
très simple l'om est depuis le début a
donné un plan d'action tout le monde
fait des tests massif en amont les tests
n'ont pas eu lieu équipés avec des
masques les masques on en a pas et puis
on a des traitements expérimentaux qui
sont sur le marché depuis plusieurs
temps alors on fait bien sûr discovery
aujourd'hui avec 800 patients mais que
de temps perdu
on aurait pu essayer tous ces
traitements depuis un mois essayer de
voir ce qu'il fallait aider nos amis
italiens on n'a pas aidé nos amis
italiens encore une fois on les a
regardés l'europe a regardé en disant oh
là là ce qui se passe en italie c'est
terrible ça nous arrive maintenant
simplement avec le retard temporel mais
pas du tout avec le retard géographique
puisque on vit sur un continent et que
ce virus est bien il se trimballe parce
qu'on n'a pas arrêté on n'a pas coupé
les frontières on n'a pas arrêté les
avions et a toujours autant de monde
dans les aéroports et dans les gares etc
donc toutes les réponses qui ont été
celles de gestion de crise ont été le
choix non dits de l'immunité de groupe
vous savez le fait de dire que tout le
monde aura ce virus et puis il y aura
des livres à des pots cassés c'était le
non dit et puis on se rend compte que
les pots cassés va y avoir un
extrêmement beaucoup hélas quand on est
de dire
jean on n'est pas prêt non plus à avoir
un bilan de génocidaires donc là on
change complètement braquer mais
beaucoup trop tard à moi deux mois après
mois je ne décolère pas depuis les
annonces d'agnès butin qui disait
qu'elle savait que les élections
n'auraient pas dû avoir lieu que la
crise qui était devant nous était
terrible que de temps perdu
pour rappel le conseil scientifique
autour d' emmanuel macron il a été mis
en place seulement à la mi mars
uniquement à la mi mars
avant ça c'est des choix totalement
délétère qui ont été faits le fait
d'appeler les français à voter le fait
d'appeler les français aller au théâtre
le fait de continuer comme si de rien
n'était pour préserver l'économie
aujourd'hui on a et une crise sanitaire
et une crise économique et des généraux
en place des dirigeants en place selon
comment ils veulent s'appelait puisque
certains on appelle à l'armée de l'ombre
pour rejoindre l'armée des agriculteurs
qui essaye de se dédouaner qui essaye de
faire peser cette menace sur et la
responsabilité sur l'ensemble du peuple
français
ne nous trompons pas les ordres et les
choix qui ont été faits depuis le début
de cette crise sont calamiteux monsieur
poulin merci d'avoir été avec mon direct
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
cofondateur de la revue le monde moderne
merci